[Music]
President Trump has talked about working
with Democrats when the new Congress is
seated in January Republicans held on to
their majority in the Senate flipping
some seats held by Democrats Senator Joe
Manchin of West Virginia is one of the
few Democrats to be reelected in the
state easily won by President Trump he
joins us now from Charleston West
Virginia senator Manchin good morning
good to have you here this morning
good morning Noah how are you I'm well
we're going to talk about a lot of the
big news involving the firing of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions but first
I just want to get your thoughts on what
has happened in LA this morning I just I
just really watched it on your station
it's just horrible just another tragedy
and it continues just the whole dialogue
everything that goes on that the
rhetoric the demeanor that comes from so
many people and words do have meaning
and if people think this is the Normand
are going to think that basically you
know just to do as they please and we're
hoping that we can calm this down it
starts with all of us nor it starts at
the top from the President on down to
each one of us elected officials showing
civility to each other showing basically
tolerance showing that this is a
wonderful wonderful country where the
hope of the world coming together trying
to work together we've got to be able to
show that and we've got to be able to
mean it and if not people are going to
think that they take all their take all
of their inner feelings and all of the
been up hatred out into the streets I
don't know I just it's just it's
concerning and we've got to bring this
country back when I ask you about the
big news yesterday that affects all of
us and that is the firing of the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions you were
the only Democrat to have voted for him
are we approaching a constitutional
crisis I think we're on the verge of
that here's where I think we are first
of all Jeff Sessions is a good person
I've known Jeff and we were friends and
I was the only Democrat that voted for
him but I needed Jeff the rule all meant
everything to Jeff I knew that and I
think he stuck with that and you know he
was much more to the right than
many people are then I was but just a
good man and and good he was grounded I
think it's a big mistake to let Jeff
Sessions goes I understand the Moller
investigation is wrapping up you ought
to have the team in place to wrap it up
so there's no questions and the
president says there's nothing to it
that'll show up and nor I think there's
a question about congressional oversight
here as you know mr. Whittaker who was
the chief of staff a political appointee
who is now in charge as Attorney General
was never confirmed so in some people's
minds it's the first time you've had a
non confirmed person acting as the
Attorney General of the United States
well that's that's concerning first of
all most of all these appointments are
political appointments so I don't that
doesn't raise my concerns what raises my
concerns as a person has been so vocal
against the investigation that was going
on now putting in charge a day after the
election I think that sheds bad light on
it I think that gives concern to every
senator Democrat and Republican we are a
country the rule of law is everything is
how we gauge ourselves it's out we we
govern ourselves looking like it's all
been tilted one way or the other is
wrong what you do about it senator
you've expressed your concerns if I go
back on what will you do about it nor we
go back on Tuesday we had as this Gail
yes yes okay okay Gail hi how are you
what we'll do is go back on Tuesday and
I think that we had legislation ready to
go that protected Mahler kept him in
place let him complete and finish I
would hope that we can bring that back
up have the support bipartisan support
to protect this investigation to get it
completed I think the American people
want that I think the president would
want that to let this thing come out to
the end and see what's there he said
quite frankly many many times
there's no collusion there's nothing
involved we'll be able to see that but
if you throw a veil on this thing at the
last hour of the day thinking that now
you're trying to cover something you're
trying to prevent something or the facts
from coming out I just want to make sure
that we're able to get to the
the end of this investigation with the
team in place right now that team has
been disrupted and if they pull Rosen
Stein out which they done Gail were in
trouble
senator then is it your operating
assumption that the President does want
this gotten rid of essentially and that
that's what this naming means and
secondly you're on the Intelligence
Committee when are you going to report
well basically when the Moller
investigation took over we did not go
down that path we've we've done
everything and turned everything over
and Muller investigation is the one that
we're all you know basically hinging on
sorry for that to be done so we're gonna
speak up we're going to speak out and
speak out all right senator Manchin we
thank always against the clock yeah I
know that's a way good thank you